king g2 knight h4 is coming so king g1  would have been played  yeah now only chance for  anish is to flag but  he's 20 seconds behind i mean there is  no chance it's just hopelessly lost  and to flag alireza is  it hasn't happened too many times  [Laughter]  yes yes i understand  wow 12 seconds and this looks like  alireza is going to take this one  yeah i mean okay anish is down to 10  seconds some incredible miracle has to  happen black can't even move yeah  whoa wow quincy but look d8 checkmate  finished  that's it  that is it and with that armageddon  alireza having to win on demand and he  does it he does it winning his match  against anish giri  what a day of chess  yeah what an incredible fight yeah  finally